Do you have a trip coming up
and you need to bring all of your chargers and cords
and you don't want them to get all mixed up.
This little thing from the TikTok shop,
it looks like the dumbest little thing.
Like, oh,
I could put my chart.
I know how to keep track of my chargers when I'm gone.
Um,
the thing is, when you need to charge so many fucking things
and nothing brings their own fucking block,
so you have to have a million little blocks.
I keep an extra set of wired headphones just in case,
my backup battery.
And then here I can keep all the cords for everything
separated from like the longer ones and the shorter ones.
Nothing goes missing. Holds everything.
Look how nicely.
And then you just zip it back up and don't lose anything.
And then I have a visual to see.
Do I have everything?
Every charger and cord type thing that I brought with me.
Is it coming back home with me?
Cause it has a designated space.
This thing is a lifesaver for traveling and keeping your shit together.
Cause I don't wanna fucking replace all those things.